license and registration not that one
the one for dexter morgan
who could have found me out a podcaster
from out of town
could be
hey guys pete here today i'm going to do
another dexter new blood video i'm going
to look at the episode 6 description
break down the next on teaser trailer
and then i'll get into some theories
about where things might be going if any
of that sounds like spoilers to you then
this is both your warning and chance to
leave and with that out of the way let's
get right into it
episode 6 is titled too many tuna
sandwiches and we did have mentioned in
the first episode that part of dexter's
daily routine involves eating one of
those from the iron lake tavern for
lunch the official description from
showtime reads someone in iron lake has
discovered jim lindsey's secret identity
sending dexter on the prowl to find out
who it was this pursuit leads him to
realize that he might not be the only
serial killer in town meanwhile harrison
spirals out of control during a
wrestling match and angela makes a dark
discovery of her own the next on trailer
opens with angela pulling over jim
lindsey like she did in the premiere it
looks like he's ready for some spicy
role play based on the look on his face
which quickly goes sour when she shows
him the obituary she printed out at the
end of episode 5. she wants to see his
other id the one for dexter morgan and
the look on his face says that he had no
idea that this was coming she's holding
proof of who he was and what he's been
hiding and there is no way that he can
deny that that's his picture and i do
think it's worth stressing that this is
an obituary as in her boyfriend didn't
just change his name and start over in a
new town he faked his own death and
there's a lot to contemplate there so
i'll come back around to the
complications that that introduces when
i get into the theories at the station
esther tells him whatever he did to
angela to make her mad just say sorry so
the people around her know that there's
an issue between them then as dexter's
looking at molly's podcast page we hear
who could have found me out a podcaster
from out of town could be he clicks on
the bay harbor butcher page to give it a
listen and that gives us a doc sighting
and we can read the episode description
that says a cop turned brutal serial
killer vigilante who killed criminals
who couldn't be caught dozens of bodies
dismembered meticulously wrapped and
buried at the bottom of the ocean
it's funny being a viewer who knows more
than the characters because that's
really the first time it actually felt
like doakes was a plausible suspect you
also see the ice truck killer episode on
the page which she did mention in the
trinity episode that showtime uploaded
to their youtube page and then you see
that dexter is stalking her trying to
figure out if she's the one that pointed
angela in his direction it's a good
question and a conclusion you might
expect dexter to jump to as he's trying
to figure things out a lot of fans had
landed there in their early theories so
i will be coming back to that as well
then there are some shots from a
wrestling match it looks like dexter's
there to watch and we can guess that
this is where the line about harrison
spiraling out of control from the
description comes into play we don't see
much and i'm not sure what to expect
here but it isn't hard to imagine that
he might act out or get violent if
things aren't going his way that's
followed up by harrison saying it hasn't
exactly been easy being jim's son and we
see that he's in a therapy session which
they did get the ball rolling in that
direction in the last episode although i
don't think he made his first
appointment here it looks like he's
jumping in and it looks like dexter has
joined him for a family session or
something like that when the therapist
questions what he means about it not
being easy being jim's son you see that
deb is there too which i found pretty
hilarious she's concerned over what
harrison might say but i think it's been
established that at least when he's not
wasted he'd rather not bring attention
their way
that cuts to kurt standing in front of
the truck stop where it looks like he
might have found a replacement for chloe
since she messed up his ritual in his
last kill cycle there's a new young
woman with a backpack standing alone
outside and it looks like he has her in
his sights after that there's a quick
sequence of angela and teddy walking
through the forest and then you see her
inside a cave with a headlamp looking at
something off screen this is definitely
interesting even without context about
how they ended up there because kurt
definitely seemed like he reacted when
she mentioned that they were expanding
the search to the caves not long after
that he revealed that he got the
facetime call from matt which we know
was a lie then the trailer comes to an
end with angela asking dexter if he was
running from something in her office
this is the big question he'll have to
answer and i mean it's dexter so coming
up with lies is one of his super powers
but angela is no dummy and she does have
resources at her disposal as a police
officer and she's made a connection with
miami through batista where she could
probably call him anytime she needs to
the story he crafts is gonna have to
take all of that into consideration and
i suppose this is the point where we can
transition into talking about theories
when you think about what dexter might
tell her you have to take into
consideration all the public information
that she can find on her own so rita's
death would play a part in that and the
fact that harrison was there when she
was killed i think the most popular idea
i've seen in the comments and elsewhere
on the internet is that dexter will use
the idea of his family being afraid of
trinity since he killed arthur mitchell
and disposed of the body the public
doesn't know what happened to the
trinity killer angela will likely know
that trinity killed his wife and so he
could probably play it off like he was
running from that several years did pass
between when she died and he faked his
own death but perhaps he could just add
something about deben to that story and
as mentioned lying is not something he
has a problem with he was always really
quick on his feet in that department and
we have seen a couple of examples of
that in new blood as well nobody knows
that dexter morgan was a serial killer
so it's not like anyone's actually
looking for him but at the same time i
can't see him being able to stay in iron
lake if he couldn't give her something
that satisfied her completely so that
she wasn't interested in looking into
his past at all and then that brings up
this connection to molly park who
happens to be a walking encyclopedia
when it comes to the cases that he was
involved in it could be particularly bad
for him if angela was to tell her what
she found out there are two things that
stand out about molly that make it hard
to know her motivations the first is
that she just arrived out of the blue in
iron lake a couple of days after matt
went missing there was really no
explanation for this angela did confront
her about saying she was a concerned
citizen there to help rather than a
podcaster out to tell a story but we
never heard why she came to iron lake in
the first place it's not a big city matt
wasn't gone for that long it's not the
kind of place you just show up to that's
led to a lot of theories that she
already knows who dexter is and that's
the real story she's after but why would
she be on his trail obviously she's done
podcasts about three different cases he
was involved with the trinity killer the
bay harbor butcher which is dexter
obviously but the official story is that
it's james doakes and the ice truck
killer but she would have had to pick up
on something that everyone else missed
to even suspect that he was related to
those beyond trinity killing rita then
she would have had to find him as well
and i'm not saying that it rules it out
i'm just saying we need more information
to go off there's still a lot of mystery
about what's going on with molly i would
be shocked if her background didn't come
into play and she did seem slightly
skeptical about the official story when
she was telling angela about the bay
harbor butcher but there's still a lot
of dots to connect there and it looks
like right now she's gonna be on
dexter's radar
where we're at now there's kind of a lot
of dangling threads ed olsen hasn't been
around in the last couple of episodes i
still lean towards him being audrey's
biological father out of the theories
that are out there and him not being
around hasn't changed that i think it's
obvious he has a role to play in the
bigger picture after kurt was confirmed
to be the killer i saw more people
talking about maybe he was involved with
the girls after they were killed
something like he was the one embalming
them or they're working together to
display these bodies somewhere i don't
really see what indicates that other
than he kind of looks shady i mean the
killing's been going on for a long time
he seems to do this regularly at least
he shows up at the tavern every couple
of months to play runaway and dance with
the bartender and we see that he's very
specific about his ritual which i
imagine we'll learn about the origin of
that in the next couple of episodes i
don't really see a straight line to ed
olsen being involved with that so we'll
have to wait and see we do see angela in
the caves here and i think it's likely
she's gonna find out something about
these girls because we know from the
other trailers that she'll eventually
find the cabin and i don't know it just
seems silly to me that they would embalm
these bodies and put them in the cave
but can totally understand that that's
kind of how things add up so i hope
there's a good reason or something funny
about how that plays out because it
doesn't sound great i suppose there's a
possibility he might have dumped chloe's
body there because it wasn't right for
the rest of the ritual maybe that's
happened before and that's why he was
worried about the search it's hard to
say there's still the whole thing about
matt being dead and no one knowing that
except for dexter we're also kind of at
a standstill about what's going on with
harrison at the end of the last episode
he was ready to leave town as far as we
know if kurt hadn't talked to him he
would have left dexter's interpretation
of trying to be a good dad after the od
was to leave harrison without really
talking to him about what happened and
go hunt down the guy who sold him the
drugs finding out why he had the
straight razor and why he used it to
slash ethan got put on hold i'm still
leaning towards harrison not being the
same as dexter in relation to the dark
passenger but i'm waiting to see what
happens at this wrestling match and at
the therapy session because something's
going on with him i think dexter is
going to learn something about kurt
while he's stalking molly maybe she'll
be stalking him after seeing the guy
using matt's cards at the hotel i think
kurt will continue to try to get close
to harrison and that's going to cause
dexter to want to get to him before the
police do it's very possible that kurt
will figure out that there's something
going on with dexter in that
relationship and there's a lot of
potential for fireworks there once
angela learns that her instincts about a
local serial killer are correct and
she'll be focused on finding out who it
is that may make things a little easier
for dexter to put her off about his past
but it's not really clear how she's
going to respond to being lied to in the
first place i don't think it's a given
that they'll continue to stay together
and i think that's a good place to leave
things let me know what you're thinking
about in the comments and what theories
you're hoping will be correct please
like this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon